if I got the group-date Rose tonight I  would feel really special because I  really haven't felt like I stood out in  front of all the other girls yet I had  you know group date stage fright today  boy it's my first one so it didn't  really know what to expect this group  date setting is way different than my  one-on-one date setting and that's what  I'm used to I'm used to being spoiled  and just getting his attention so now  I'm just kind of a little shyer because  I want to stand out but not in a loud  obnoxious way I just want him to notice  me Kayla was somebody on the first date  with her I wonder if there be passion  there she's so sweet she has this huge  smile and she's so like innocent and  like we get alone and she's just like  tigress like this is like a sex